this is our trash can I just landed in
Sacramento and I'm here to visit a
zero-waste family but I've been
following on Instagram for about a year
and I'm really excited to meet them
because I want to see how a family lives
here at least this is how much trash
that our family made in six months we're
a family of four and we try to live as
low waste and plant-based as possible
our family is able to create less waste
because we shop at the farmers market we
shop at our bulk store and we eat
plant-based this is not all of our trash
this is just the trash that we've kept
that is gonna go to the landfill we also
recycle and compost this is our compost
weekly pickup this is our paper
recycling this is usually full of my
stuff of aluminum they sent me an
amazing lunch and then we headed to the
co-op to do some shopping
I cannot believe this book section but
every income we're lucky so this gives
you the weight of the jar and then they
deducted after that cash exactly about
what you only have to pay for what's
inside not the way to this work I'm
gonna get some of the extra virgin olive
oil and I can just fill it up out of
here with no plastic they have the means
of jars there are
so you can just purchase one if you
forget your own it has the tare weight
on it
you're such a good helper I gotta get my
olkhon while I'm here
the co-op has brought over tofu which is
amazing because it's local and organic
and there's no plastic package and what
did your kitchen used to look like
before you went zero waste it was
stuffed to the brim with plastic like it
was really hard to see in the fridge
even because we just would go to Costco
or to create our joes and stuff and just
get foods that were wrapped in plastic
because I mean that's just how things
come unfortunately here's my pantry and
here I've got all my spices I store most
of our stuff in mason jars just because
it's so convenient I honestly cannot
believe your pantry I'm so jealous it's
like beautiful look at it it's amazing I
came to a plant-based diet after I was
looking for a way to heal my body
holistically from rheumatoid arthritis
and after I started eating that way
started to feel really good and so I got
my family to eat that way too and it
felt amazing and also ties in a lot with
zero waste and sustainability we got
into zero waste by me coming across
Fayed Johnson in an article and I was
really inspired by the way that she was
able to live and create less waste and
so we went really in at first of trying
to get everything zero waste and it just
didn't work that way for us and so we
scaled back and just did more manageable
steps one at a time and built our habits
that way
eating zero waste plant-based from the
family
has been very beneficial we're finding
ourselves getting sick less often we're
giving as a family as a whole all
pitching in cooking together going to
the farmers market the kids are growing
it they're seeing it from seed to plate
I think that overall we have ended up
saving money as far as not any of our
food going to waste I'll use all the
food that we buy and as far as not using
any disposable products it's a lot less
expensive that way because all our stuff
is being reused the other kids I
surprised at my lunches because I don't
think they have ever really seen
something like that so it's a new thing
for them I'm gonna shuck some corn with
the kids do you guys like helping to
cook yeah I like helping to cook because
I want to like speak up to we're having
a delicious dinner thank you so much
thank you we got toothpaste for make
your face I make our own toothpaste with
baking soda and coconut oil and
peppermint essential oil hey unsolved is
on a new channel and know your part
subscribe here that was my part